you just lost your capitalist
model you have a model with two inputs
called K and L that's taught in every
University that subscribes to
neoclassical economics what's AI is it l
is it labor is it capital what the heck
is it this is the first time that humans
are not being chased into higher and
higher levels of work we're being chased
out of repetitive work whether it's high
level repetitive work in the way that a
neurosurgeon might perform or lowlevel
repetitive work so your model of
Economics just
broke now when your water breaks when
your wife's water breaks it doesn't mean
that the baby is born instantly when the
contractions are coming you know 15
minutes apart it's not yet time to be
born this is the moment why are we not
holding a conference on uh after
capitalism and communism what is the
next economic system do you imagine that
Adam Smith uh and Carl Marx would just
be sitting on on their hands no they'd
be smart enough to say okay we now need
a new model it is bizarre that we are
sitting here inert
saying
gosh this is going to break capitalism
well no kidding this is going to break
capitalis it's entirely clear that it's
going to break
capitalism
and you have this fabric it's really
fascinating you have a fabric that is
overlying the entire world that directs
people whe whether to get up in the
morning and what to do once they once
they do rise and it tells them how to do
things without having a dictator so this
it's not just the Invisible Hand it's
the invisible mesh and this invisible
mesh if it breaks means people are not
going to know what to do in the morning
and now you can see that this is going
to break it now you have a brief period
of time with what my wife uh has called
it she's an economist with the institute
for New Economic thinking she says this
is the Golden Age of AI complimentarity
where a human being makes making prompts
can ask the large language model or
neural net whatever whatever you like
questions and the two of them in
dialogue can create something it's sort
of like when humans and computers
started playing chess together this is
going to quickly give way to where the
AI says I can take it from here and how
quick do you think it's going to be Eric
probably pretty quick but keep in mind
that there's some things that could
happen
because what these machines are doing is
reading a human
Corpus uh when it comes to language
models let's say it could be that they
ASM toote based on how clever we've been
for example they don't do a very good
job in areas where there are fewer than
200 people writing about a very high
level scientific subject so I ask these
computer models a lot about determinant
line bundles not something in
general uh conversation and they're
terrible at it because they don't know
what to read or how much they don't have
enough so it's possible that I that that
could ASM toote but the thing you really
have to keep in mind is that a clever
person at one of these AI outfits might
figure out how to teach computers to do
things that no one has done so we know
that they have emergent behaviors that
you may not teach them Bengali but they
realize they have to learn Bengali in
order to tell you about tagor so learn
Bengali they do that's an emergent
Behavior what happens when they start to
uh well you know I hesitate to give you
an example because I think this could be
weaponized so maybe I'm not going to say
what I think you could actually teach
one of these machines to
do all hell's about to break loose and
my question is are are you trying to
figure out which way the wave is going
to break and get your surfboard in the
water are you are you trying to figure
out how to anticipate this no in general
we say sit around worrying about it in
the most inert way possible and I just
don't understand the Learned
helplessness this is the your wife's
water is broken and you're thinking this
is terrible it's like you you have to be
thinking get to the hospital agreed
temperamentally I'm with you but I think
what Francis is getting at is look I
introduced you as one of the smartest
people in the world I stand by that
introduction there are also some other
smart people who some of whom are saying
we got to shut the down right now
we need a moratorium we can't allow this
to how's that working I I I don't agree
that no no I'm not saying whether it's a
good idea or a bad idea what I'm saying
is how is it working when China exactly
and Russia and Iran are reading these
papers that's why it's not going to work
and I I agree with you but my I think
our question that we're trying to get at
is why is are people like Elon Musk so
concerned about AI because he's
smart because he doesn't see anybody
really I mean look I don't know Elon and
I are sort of leading parallel lives he
must be aware of me sometimes answers me
on on Twitter and sometimes we encounter
each other in spaces but we know
probably 25 people in common at a very
high level we never encounter each other
I can't tell you what's going on with
Elon Elon is on all of the major
narratives and I 90 to 95% agree with
him on everything right up until the
very end and I don't know why that goes
wrong but his whole narrative about
getting off the planet and diversifying
the number of places where the spark of
human consciousness can be found without
having all of our eggs in one basket
100% right and then it becomes a SpaceX
pitch for Mars which loses me but then
again I don't own a chemical rocket
company in the case of AI you know the
fact is he was seeing this early and he
saw Sam Alman make these other decisions
they were all at this PTO you know I
think Sam wasn't at the Puerto Rico
conference but all of these folks who
are at the Puerto Rico conference knew
that this was coming now 2017 is the
dividing line I think in AI because this
paper attention is all you need makes it
clear to all of us not through the paper
but through the
consequences that this is as real as a
heart
attack